Adria says you're on GCP are three of
the world's largest cloud service
providers but how are they different
from each other let's find out hey guys
I'm wrong and I'll be representing
Amazon Web Services
I'm shin myeon I'll be representing
Microsoft Azure and I am Shruti and I'll
be representing Google cloud platform so
welcome to this video on AWS was as a
Java sis GCP talking about market share
Amazon Web Services leads with around
32% of the worldwide public cloud share
Jean Jean percent of the worldwide
market share and GCP owns around nine
percent of the world's market share
let's talk about each of these service
providers in detail a SS provides
services that enable users to create and
deploy applications over the cloud these
services are accessible via the Internet
it abuse being the oldest of the lot was
launched in the year 2006 Asscher
launched in 2010 is a computing platform
that offers a wide range of services to
build manage and deploy applications on
the network using tools and frameworks
launched in the year 2008 GCP offers
application development and integration
services for its end-users in addition
to cloud management it also offers
services for big data machine learning
and IOT now let's talk about
availability zone these are isolated
locations within data center regions
from which public cloud services
originate and operate talking about AWS
they have 69 availability zones within
22 geographical regions this includes
regions in the United States South
America Europe and Asia Pacific they are
also predicted to have 12 more editions
in the future as you're available in 140
countries has over 54 regions worldwide
grouped into six geographies these
geographical locations have more than
100 data centers GCP is available in 200
plus countries across the world as of
today GCP is present in 61 zones and 20
regions with Osaka and Zurich being the
newly added regions now let's talk about
pricing these services follow the
pay-as-you-go approach you pay only for
the individual services you need for as
long as you use them without requiring
long-term contracts or complex licensing
now on screen you can see the pricing
for each of these cloud service
providers with
to various instances like
general-purpose computer optimized
memory optimized and GPU now let's talk
about the compute services offered first
off we have virtual service for AWS we
have ec2 it is a web service which
eliminates the need to invest in
hardware so that you can develop and
deploy applications in a faster manner
it provides virtual machines in which
you can run your applications while jaws
virtual machines is one of the several
types of computing resources that assure
offers as your gives the user the
flexibility to deploy and manage a
virtual environment inside a virtual
network GCPs vm service enables users to
build deploy and manage virtual machines
to run workloads on the cloud now let's
talk about the pricing of each of these
services a WCC 2 is free to try it is
packaged as part of a dubious is feed
here that lasts for 12 months and
provides 750 hours per month of both
Linux and Windows virtual machines as
your virtual machine service is a part
of the free tier that offers the service
for about 750 hours per month for a year
the user gets access to Windows and
Linux virtual machines GCPs vm service
is a part of a free tier that includes
micro instance per month for up to 12
months now let's talk about platform as
a service or past services for AWS
elastic Beanstalk is an easy to use
service for deploying and scaling web
applications and services developed with
java.net node.js Python and much more it
is used for maintaining capacity
provisioning load balancing auto scaling
and application has mantri the past
backbone utilizes virtualization
techniques where the virtual machine is
independent of the actual hardware that
hosts it
hence the user can write application
code without worrying about the
underlying hardware Google App Engine is
a cloud computing platform as a service
which is used by developers for hosting
and building apps in Google data centers
the App Engine requires the apps to be
written in Java or Python and store data
in Google BigTable and use the Google
query language for this next let's talk
about virtual private server services
AWS provides lightsail it provides
everything you need to build an
application or website along with the
cost-effective monthly plan and minimum
number of configurations in simple words
VM
is a more comprehensive image for
Microsoft Azure virtual machines it
helps the user create many identical
virtual machines in a matter of minutes
unfortunately GCP does not offer any
similar service next up we have
serverless computing services AWS has
lambda it is a serval as compute service
that lets you run your code without
facilitating and managing servers you
only pay for the compute time you use it
is used to execute back in code and
skills automatically when required as
your functions is a serval as compute
service that lets you run even triggered
code without having to explicitly
provision or manage infrastructure this
allows the users to build applications
using server less simple functions with
the programming language of their choice
GCP cloud functions make it easy for
developers to run and scale code in the
cloud and build image driven serverless
applications it is highly available and
fault tolerant now let's talk about
storage services offered by each of
these service providers first off we
have object storage AWS provides s3 it
is an object storage that provides
industry standard scalability data
availability and performance it is
extremely durable and can be used for
storing as well as recovering
information or data from anywhere over
the Internet
blob storage is an azure feature that
lets developers store unstructured data
in Microsoft's cloud platform along with
storage it also offers scalability it
stores the data in the form of tiers
depending on how often data is being
accessed Google Cloud Storage is an
online storage web service for storing
and accessing data on Google cloud
platform infrastructure unlike the
Google Drive Google Cloud Storage is
more suitable for enterprises it also
shows objects that are organized into
buckets Amazon provides EBS or elastic
block store it provides high-performance
block storage and it's used along with
ec2 instances for workloads that are
transaction or throughput intensive as
your managed disk is a virtual hard disk
you can think of it like a physical disk
in an on-premises server but virtualized
these managed disks allow the users to
create up to 10,000 VM disks in a single
subscription persistent storage is a
data storage device that retains data
after power to the devices shut off
Google persistent disk is durable
and high-performance block storage for
GCP persistent disk provides storage
which can be attached to instances
running in either Google compute engine
or Cuban ''tis engine next up we have
disaster recovery services AWS provides
a cloud-based recovery service that
ensures that your IT infrastructure and
data are recovered while minimizing the
amount of downtime that could be
experienced site recovery heads and
short business continuity by keeping
business apps and workloads running
during outages it allows recovery by
orchestrating and automating the
replication process of assured virtual
machines between regions unfortunately
GCP has no disaster recovery service
next let's talk about database services
first off for AWS we have RDS or
relational database service it is web
service that's cost effective and
automates administration tasks basically
it simplifies the set up operation and
scaling of a relational database
Microsoft Azure SQL database is a
software as a service platform that
includes built-in intelligence that
learns app patterns and adapts to
maximize performance reliability and
data protection it also eases the
migration of SQL Server databases
without changing the users applications
cloud SQL is a fully managed database
service which is easy to set up maintain
and administer relational PostgreSQL
MySQL and SQL Server databases in the
cloud hosted on GCP cloud SQL provides a
database infrastructure for applications
running anywhere next we have no SQL
database services AWS provides DynamoDB
which is a managed durable database that
provides security backup and restore and
in memory caching for applications it is
well known for its low latency and
scalable performance as your cosmos DB
is Microsoft's globally distributed
multi model database service it natively
supports no SQL it natively supports no
SQL created for low latency and scalable
applications GCP cloud datastore is a no
SQL database service offered by Google
on the GCP
it handles replication and scales
automatically to your applications load
with cloud datastore interface data can
easily be accessed by any deployment
target now let's talk about the key
cloud tools for
of these service providers for AWS in
networking and content delivery we have
a SS route 53 and AWS cloud front for
management we have AWS cloud watch an
AWS CloudFormation for development we
have a tubeless code star and AWS code
built for security we have a.m. and key
management service for Microsoft Azure
networking and content delivery we have
content delivery network and Express
route for management tools we have as
your advisor and network watcher for
development tools for management we have
as your advisor and network watcher for
development we have Visual Studio IDE
and a short blop studio for security we
have a short security center and as your
active directory for GCP we have the
following tools for networking and
content delivery we have clout Syrian
and cloud DNS for management we have
stackdriver and GCP monitoring for
development we have cloud build and
cloud SDK and finally for security we
have Google cloud I am and Google and
cloud security scanner now let's talk
about the companies using these cloud
providers for AWS we have Netflix
Unilever Kellogg's NASA Nokia and Adobe
Pixar Samsung eBay Fujitsu EMC and BMW
among others use Microsoft Azure so as
seen on your screens the companies at
use GCP are spotify hsbc snapchat
twitter paypal and twentieth century-fox
let's talk about the advantages of each
of these services Amazon provides
enterprise friendly services you can
leverage Amazon's 15 years of experience
delivering large-scale global
infrastructure and it still continues to
hone and innovate its infrastructure
management skills and capabilities
secondly it provides instant access to
resources
AWS is designed to allow application
providers IVs and vendors to quickly and
securely host your applications whether
an existing application or a new SAS
based application speed and agility AWS
provides you access to its services
within minutes all you need to select is
what you require and you can proceed you
can access each of these applications
anytime you need them and finally its
secure and reliable Amazon enables you
to innovate and scale your application
in a secure environment it secures and
hardens your infrastructure more
importantly it provides security at a
cheaper cost and optimized environments
now talking about some of the advantages
of assur Microsoft Azure
offers better development opera
it also provides strong security profile
jean has a strong focus on security
following the standard security model of
detect assess diagnose stabilize and
close a shawl also provides a
cost-effective solution the cloud
environment allows businesses to launch
both customer applications and internal
apps in the cloud which saves an IT
infrastructure costs hence its effects
friendly let's now look at the
advantages of GCP Google bills in minute
level increments so you only pay for the
compute time you use they also provide
discounted prices for long-running
workloads for example you use the VM for
a month and get a discount GCP also
provides live migration of virtual
machines live migration is the process
of moving a running VM from one physical
server to another without disrupting its
availability to the users this is a very
important differentiator for Google
Cloud compared to other cloud providers
GCP provides automatic scalability this
allows a sites container scale to as
many CPUs as needed Google Cloud Storage
is designed for 99.9% durability it
creates server backup and stores them in
an user configure location let's talk
about the disadvantages of each of these
services for AWS there's a limitation of
the ec2 service it obvious provides
limitations on resources that vary from
region to region there may be a limit to
the number of instances that can be
created however you can request for
these limits to be increased secondly
they have a technical support fee aw
charges to you for immediate support and
you can opt for any of these packages
developer which costs $29 per month
business which costs more than $100 an
enterprise that costs more than $15,000
it has certain network connectivity
issues
it also has general issues when you move
to the cloud like downtime limited
control backup protection and so on
however most of these are temporary
issues and can be handled over time
talking about some of the disadvantages
of Microsoft a short code base is
different when working offline and it
requires modification when working on
the cloud pass echo system is not as
efficient as IaaS as your management
console is frustrating to work with it
is slow to respond and update and
requires far too many clicks to achieve
simple tasks as your backup is intended
for backing up and restoring data
located on your on-premises servers to
the cloud that's a great feature but
it's not
really useful for doing bare-metal to
three stores of servers in a remote data
center let's know look into the
disadvantages of GCP so when it comes to
cloud providers the support fee is very
minimal but in the case of GCP it is
quite costly it is around 150 dollars
per month for the most basic service
similar to AWS s3 JCB has a complex
pricing schema also it is not very
budget-friendly when it comes to
downloading data from Google Cloud
storage
and with that we reached the end of this
video I hope you guys found this
informative and helpful thank you for
watching and stay tuned for more from
simply Ludd hi there if you like this
video subscribe to the simple learn
youtube channel and click here to watch
similar videos Dinard up and get
certified click here